but it is 1 month without a drop of
alcohol you're making me cry again you
are a completely different functioning
person and I am so proud of you jacn
this is
[Music]
huge super quick here folks I really
want to talk about my sponsor today
homog glob so I'm a super organized
person but I'm a very messy person and
this is quite the Dilemma for me because
I cannot feel organized when things are
messy so I really appreciate the value
of having someone with actual cleaning
skills who like sees a pile and puts it
away to come and lend some much needed
support So homog glow is a five-star
cleaning service with super affordable
prices way cheaper than most services
that I've paid for in the past and
definitely worth it to save my marriage
and my ability to get work done but the
way it works is you go to home hom
Glow's website to choose the day and
time that you're looking for and the
duration of your cleaning and you'll be
able to see all the available cleaners
along with their background checks
photos and reviews so if you have
someone that you've worked with before
you can rebook that same person and you
can schedule it for that week or like a
month from now if you want to rebook
your cleanings on a regular basis you
can also sign up for their forever clean
membership which saves you $30 an hour
on future cleanings or unlimited
cleanings for $19 an hour hour all of
which are backed by their happiness
guarantee and the cleaners are really
super incentivized to do a good job
because 100% of the cleaning fees and
tips go directly to them I don't know
about you but I just feel like I can
work so much more efficiently and calmly
when I'm not living in chaos this
service is only available in the United
States but if you need a little
occasional support for your mental
health or to take a huge domestic Duty
off of your plate head to homog glow.com
slabby or scan the QR code to get your
first 3 hours of cleaning for only $19
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
aby's Kitchen today we'll be catching up
with our girl jacn on her journey and
talking more broadly about what happens
to your body and weight when you stop
drinking this comes at a time in the
year when traditionally there is a lot
of excessive drinking when binge
drinking basically becomes part of the
culture and it's borderline acceptable
to get blackout drunk at the company
party L it her head it's happening
it is also a time when stress depression
and anxiety related to finances family
and past trauma can result in people
turning to alcohol to cope it can be a
really hard season for a lot of folks
with histories of misuse of alcohol or
who want to explore reducing their
regular use but if you are Sober Sober
curious or just looking to cut back I do
recommend watching Jacqueline's video in
its entirety I'm just going to give you
the CO's notes of where she's at up
until I went through a traumatic
incident I partied I drink alcohol
socially I was just drinking like
everybody else right when I launched my
lipsticks that was the worst time of my
entire life and during that time I
turned to alcohol I started drinking
alcohol in a very normal way again right
so I thought like my relationship with
alcohol is good again because this is
the way everybody drank I was no longer
using it to run but I lost like 10 to 12
lbs and it was hard work like it was not
easy cuz again I was still drinking was
I drinking you know heavily no I was
still consuming alcohol so when I went
to New York for my birthday I was
drinking sangrias and I was drinking
margaritas and I was just drinking
whatever I got home it weighed myself
and I was like oh my God I hadn't
weighed myself in several weeks so in
that time frame I had gained 12 lbs and
I was like I'm sorry we did not just
gain back everything that we lost and
that was my moment wow that is a very
powerful story and I bet at telling that
a lot of folks can identify with even if
they don't identify as having a problem
with alcohol we all have have a moment
where we realize that something in our
life is no longer serving us whether
it's a disordered eating pattern an
addiction a person a job a place Etc no
one else can get you to that point you
really have to reach that moment on your
own but after that moment Jaclyn dumped
out a bottle of Cheetos and vowed to
stop drinking and at the time of posting
she has been 90 days sober that is
amazing so let's hear about the benefits
jacine experienced thus far so when I
stopped drinking I did not do it for for
any physical effects I did it
100% for my mental health and I just
wanted to feel good that's all I cared
about I'm really happy that that was the
mindset that I had because I didn't see
any physical changes for a little bit I
started all new habits okay I started
taking walks I started eating so much
sugar and now the alcohol is far and
long gone out of my system I love sugar
I did change my diet as well I changed
my workout routine as well and now I
I've lost 23 lbs ah it's crazy you guys
it's crazy I was working my titties off
it's still sugar even if you're just
drinking clear alcohol with club soda
because now the weight literally falls
off of me now hear me out I did not lose
any weight not even a pound for the
first two weeks something happened
between like the one month Mark and the
3month mark where I lost like close to
20 lbs in 2 months I am so sharp every
single person in my life is like what
the I have so so much damn energy I
don't require as much sleep I have lost
4 in on my waist my rosacea is gone my
average heart rate has gone down by 15
beats per minute my blood work is crazy
my doctor was like this looks like a
different person first of all I am so
proud of Jacqueline like this is what
the journey should be about if you
recall Jaclyn spent months I don't know
maybe years on a weight loss journey and
even though I was rooting for her to
meet her goals as a dietitian I had a
lot of reservations about her approach
basically with each episodes we would
see jacine pull the rins super super
hard and then have a weekend out where
she would say it I'm going to live my
best life where she would drink and eat
and be married rinse and repeat and not
only is this over restrict binge repeat
cycle a very common Pitfall for people
who are trying to lose weight but the
alcohol piece was probably also playing
a significant role in The Struggle but
the fact that she went into this journey
of giving giv up alcohol not for the
promise of finally losing weight or you
know reducing the puffiness in her face
or any other physical feature but for
the mental health benefits which clearly
have been huge is so important for
maintaining motivation because like she
said she didn't see any weight loss for
a few weeks and she could have easily
said like oh my God I'm not going out
I'm miserable I can't have fun with my
friends and I have nothing to show for
it but she stayed the course and I'm so
glad she did because yeah those first
few weeks of abstinence are probably
going to be really really tough what
jacine has shared here is super Brave
and it really opens up opportunities for
more discussions like this one and since
I'm not a substance use counselor or a
psychologist I'm a dietician I wanted to
talk broadly about what happens to your
body when you stop drinking so weeks one
and two are rough so this is the
clinical detox period and when the
withdrawal effects like insomnia anxiety
depression ability night sweats Etc are
most prominent after 2 weeks your liver
is likely near or fully recovered
basically every time you use alcohol
some of your liver cells die and while
we are able to develop new cells
prolonged misuse of alcohol can reduce
its ability to regenerate so one of the
major risks of alcohol used disorder is
curosis of the liver where you get a
buildup of fats in the liver But after
those 2 weeks of abstinence you'll
likely physically see signs of liver
recovery like clear whiter eyes and
greater energy like Jaclyn later
described now after 2 weeks this is
generally where we see the most physical
and mental health benefits you'll be
sleeping better you may see improvements
in your skin better digestion and a lot
more this is also when you'll likely see
a dramatic reduction in any kind of
puffiness or bloating as you stop
holding on to excess fluid especially in
the face and it's also when you may
start to lose weight which lines up very
nicely with Jaclyn's time line and her
description of the weight loss kind of
suddenly melting off most research
suggest that lower moderate drinking is
not associated with weight gain but
excess alcohol intake is so I want to
talk about the reasons why alcohol makes
it a lot harder to lose weight and why
for a lot of folks quitting can often be
the spark that ignites the weight loss
fire so why do you lose weight when you
stop drinking reason number one you
consume fewer calories this is the most
obvious reason but if you're in the
habit of having having let's say 1 to
two drinks on a week night and 2 to
three on a weekend and I'm being
conservative even if you're choosing
perfectly clean drinks like Jaclyn
suggested that she would you are racking
up an extra th000 to 3,000 calories per
week just from the alcohol alone and
this does not include any mixes or
syrups or any late night restaurant or
bar foods that you may feel more
inclined to consume when your
inhibitions are down so of course when
you remove the calories from alcohol you
are naturally creating a calorie deficit
even if you don't change a single thing
about the food so that is Captain
Obvious reason number one reason number
two you can burn fat not just booze so
when you consume alcohol your liver
preferentially burns the alcohol which
means that calories from everything else
that you eat get stored as fat
particularly around the midsection so
this is where the pet name bear belly
comes from and it's actually this
intraabdominal fat that is the most
metabolically dangerous for your health
one study found that men who drank more
than three drinks per week were 80% more
likely to have belly fat than those who
drank less which goes to show that even
what might be considered like social
drinking quantities can increase the
risk and make it harder to lose that fat
and speaking of body composition reason
number three is that you can finally
gain or maintain muscle mass when you
quit no one ever built muscle in the bar
and so even if you are working out
frequent excessive alcohol consumption
can negatively impact muscle growth
basically alcohol appears to interfere
with signaling Pathways that tell the
body to build and retain muscle it can
also affect the hypothalamic pituitary
gonadal system which lowers our
testosterone levels and while most
research in this area have been done on
men it's important to note that women
also need a certain level of
testosterone to build muscle you'll also
just likely have more energy for
exercise if you're not bogged down by
hangovers and fatigue reason number four
you'll have fewer food cravings so we
went into detail on how cortisol affects
our body weight in my video right here
but alcohol is a stressor on the body so
it increases our cortisol levels beyond
what is normal which plays a role in
that belly fat piece or that beer belly
piece but it can also increase our
cravings for higher calorie foods
interestingly and I'm not Jaclyn's
dietician so I don't have a daytoday
play byplay here but it sounded like she
replaced her use of alcohol with sugar
as a temporary dopamine hit to help pull
her out of some of those depressive
episodes in those early weeks of the
detox and then later on as she got past
that hump she was naturally just wanting
to make choices that felt good to her
body and again this totally makes sense
as the withdrawal symptoms subsided and
our hormones regulated post detox reason
number five you'll sleep better I know
we often talk about passing out after
having a few drinks and while alcohol
may seem like a sleep aid because it's a
depressant it actually interferes with
quality sleep overc consumption of
alcohol is associated with significant
sleep disturbance lower slow wave sleep
and more rapid eye movement sleep than
normal the result is that you are
chronically fatigued and poor sleep is
consistently associated with increased
hunger hormones food cravings and
cortisol levels all of which can
increase the risk of weight game there
are obviously many other reasons why
overc consumption of alcohol can impact
your weight but the question question
remains do you have to completely
abstain to see the benefits do you need
to quit cold turkey to lose weight well
for some folks yeah it might be All or
Nothing not because of the risk of
weight gain but because even one drink
can trigger overuse some people are also
just more sensitive to the effects than
others but generally speaking the
research suggests that light to moderate
alcohol intake is not associated with
weight or fat gain so how much is too
much again highly individualized but I'm
currently of the thought that less is
more here in Canada we actually just
updated our low-risk alcohol drinking
guidelines from 10 drinks per week for
women and 15 for men to just two drinks
per week that is a huge huge leap but
these guidelines have taken into
consideration the risks of cancer heart
disease stroke and bodily harm to
yourself and others via drinking and
driving or fighting or other illegal
activity and honestly this is kind of
what I suggest sticking to as well at
two drinks per week you are very highly
unlikely to experience any of the weight
gain risk factors that we just talked
about nor any of the more important
negative mental and physical health
outcomes so if you're sober or sober
curious or just looking to cut back on
alcohol as we head into drink and
culture Prime Time with the holidays
here are some my top tips number one
learn to say no you don't have to say
yes to every single event invite that
you receive so set a weekly cap on going
out before the invitations start rolling
in and then send a thank you card with
your regrets when you've met your Mac
number two set a time limit for your
event attendance arrive at parties early
on before everyone else has had too much
to drink and commit to heading home
early to maintain your Healthy nighttime
routine number three offer or bring
non-alcoholic options a festive mocktail
cider or hot cocoa gives you something
to look forward to Beyond just Seltzer
and it's something that everyone else
can enjoy I've also learned from my
pregnancy days that it is best to have
something in your hands at all times so
that hosts or servers aren't constantly
asking you what you want to drink number
four start some non-drinking traditions
if you're hosting or organizing a
holiday event make some socializing
suggestions that don't revolve around
booze so like having a holiday movie
night or ice skating or Holiday Light
tours or night skiing are all super fun
ways to socialize without alcohol and
finally practice polite decline llies
whether you are completely abstaining or
trying to limit your consumption
practice the polite response when your
friends or family start to pressure you
to drink it could be like I'm good with
this or I'm pacing myself or I'm driving
tonight or I'm cutting back all these
are really quick responses that really
shouldn't need any more details so
there's lots of reasons to cut back on
alcohol consumption weight loss is
really just one of many and arguably is
one of the least important perks in the
context of overall health and jacine is
a really inspiring example of this she
went into her sober Journey not looking
to lose weight but ironically it made
something she had previously been
working her off for just happened the
unexpected but much desired side effect
of really changing her whole life for
the better so please whether you're a
Jaclyn fan or not leave her some love
here I really hope she sees this because
I am rooting for her 100% And I am so
glad that she had the courage to share
her journey with the rest of us and on
that note that's all that I have for you
guys I hope you have a safe and healthy
holiday season if you are someone you
know is struggling with alcohol use
disorder I'm going to leave a link below
to some resources to help and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye